chaque année des milliers d'ontariens
travers cette frontière pour établir
leur résidence permanente au québec une
fois installés certains continuent
d'immatriculer leur voiture en ontario
et même d'y payer leurs impôts une
carrosserie comme tout le monde fait
pour la taxe de nombreux contribuables
québécois surtout ici en outaouais en
ont assez de faire les frais de ce
stratagème on a moins de revenus au
québec l'impact c'est que eux profitent
du système québécois
pour la santé pour l'éducation pour
l'environnement moins cher les
propriétés non non c'est pas acceptable
bien que la pratique soit interdite
l'utilisation d'une fausse adresse pour
payer ses impôts à l'extérieur du québec
peut s'avérer très payante mais à tous
les niveaux c'est plus intéressant
d'état notariaux de façon assez
substantiel quand même dont quatre ont
fait la comparaison par tranches de
revenus
certains
contribuables qui gagnent 50 mille
dollars par année dès 2000 $ de moins en
un pot en ontario qu'au québec avec un
revenu de 100 mille dollars ces 5000 $
de moins et ainsi de suite
revenu québec d'être bien au fait du
stratagème de fausses adresses qui a
cours dans des régions frontalières
comme ottawa gatineau depuis quelques
années une équipe spécialisée dans le
domaine de la résidence fiscale à
éplucher les dossiers de près de 500
contribuables et envoyer des factures
totalisant 7 millions de dollars à 188
entre eux mêmes la sûreté du québec
s'est mise de la partie durant la
pandémie les policiers ont identifié des
résidents du québec qui avait encore une
adresse officielle en ontario ils ont
aussi reçu des dénonciations citoyens
qui soupçonnent leurs voisins de fraude
fiscale en tout une cinquantaine de
dossiers ont été référées à revenu
québec la sûreté du québec nous a déjà
dit qu'elle enquêtait sur plusieurs sur
plusieurs personnes chez que plusieurs
enquêtes qui sont ouvertes en ce moment
il ya des gens qui qui ont dû payer des
amendes des gens qui ont dit transférer
leurs leurs papiers la crainte c'est que
les sommes récupérées au cours des
dernières années ne représentent qu'une
infime partie des pertes fiscales réel
il ya des gens qui sont bien établis
depuis 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans et
qu'ils savent que le régime fiscal en
ontario l'art est plus avantageuse donc
ils trouvent une façon de contourner le
système mais c'est de la fraude 6
millions c'est ce qu'ils ont récupérés
mais ce qu'on sait pas c'est combien on
perd collectivement d'autres élus
dénoncent la situation
c'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas avoir le
meilleur de tout le monde et on trouvait
ça agace les gens donc je suis bien
content que revenu québec la sûreté du
québec aussi on le disait ce matin leur
travail dans ce dossier j invite les
gens bien sûr de l'ontario qui profitent
des services s'est par conséquent des
impôts qui sont payés par l'ensemble de
la communauté à faire ce qu'ils doivent
faire pour eux aussi contribué
financièrement ce débat risque de
prendre de l'ampleur alors que le nombre
d'ontariens qui s'installe au québec est
à la hausse ici daniel leblanc
radio-canada gatineau